ثلاث ايام ننام وين على حصمه وتعذيب
وبهدله وكلام رزيل و ويخبط عروسنا وتعذيب
وكلبشات النام بالكلبشات ورا زي هيك
وكلبشات في
الرجلين وهجمه الكلاب علينا وما خلوا حاجه
يعني بعدين ودونا على العنبر من عنبر صار
من عنبر لعنبر كل يوم ق كم من يوم ودونا
على التحقيق على المخابرات يتهمونا
اتهامات يعني
عمرنا انضمينا لتنظيمات ولا لاي بقول انت
في النخبه انت هيك هيك لك تصوير في 7
اكتوبر انك جوا في الداخل قلت طب جيب ذا
انا موجود في 7 اكتوبر جوا الفيديو طخني
قدامك قاللي لا في خمس الشهاد قلتله طب
جيبهم ما جابهم الا يلزق في ان انا ايش ان
انا في حماس وان انا قتلت جوا في الداخل
معاناه صعبه 18 ساعه و 19 ساعه نضلنا
قاعدين زي زي هيك ممنوع تحكي مع اللي جنبك
مغمى ممنوع ترفع راسك ممنوع تنزل معناه
يعني لا تطاق فش يعني حكومه بتعذب زي هيك
في اي دوله في العالم عنينا عنينا يعني
شوي ويصير معنا توحد ممنوع غير الكلام
السافل اللي علينا غير
الغلط التعذيب غير انه يتهمك انك طلعت هيك
وانت ما تطلعت ملتزم يقول لك اطلع القدير
يوقفك على رجل واحده وظلك بالكلبشات نام
في الكلبشات احنا ظلك بالكلبشات بالساعتين
بالثلاثه الحمام بقوللك لوخ
حمام ن سمحلك للحمام دقيقه
دقيقتين اه يعني احنا تمنينا انه تخن قلت
له تخني ريحني قلتله تخني ريحني لانه ماضل
اي نوع من الانسانيه الموجوده بالانسان
قلت لاهلي روح ننزل نطلع نخلي من البيت
خينا من البيت رفعنا هوياتنا مسالمين طبعا
طلعنا من البيت وظلينا ماشيين باتجاه غز
القديم زي ما تقول بقعت عجوزه في الطريق
حملتها اهلي كانوا فايتين السبكين انا
واخوي حملناها مشيناها لقدام الضبط قنا
رموها وتعالوا على جنب اخذنا
اعتقلنا كلبشنا 100 الم واعتقنا تم اعتقنا
اخذنا على دار كسرنا فيها بعد التكسير
اخذنا على المردونا كسرنا برضه بعدين
اخذنا على البردو كلبشنا ومانا وحطنا في
البردو لدرجه انه يعني اخوي وصل لحاله
الامتحان
شنك حاله في البردان وصله خبر من احد
الكباتن انه اهل استشهدوا كلهم في البيت
وربط حبل هنا وشنق غطى حاله من بطانيه
حرام وشنق حاله ول حقوف اخر شي للزبد كان
يطلع يعني من هانف كانت معان المعاناه
صعبه جدا الكلبشه تنساش عص على الادين
وانت طالع معتقل ضرب خبط دبيات في الراس
وين ما بدك ضرب في العين في الراس في واحد
عينه راحت اه في واحد عينه راحت يعني انا
اللي قدامك يعني قبلت معاصي صعبه جدا ما
كله يعني قد ما تتصور فيه معاصي وكله
بتحكم فيك وطي راسك علي راسك ماخلي راسك
في الارض صلاه فيشي طبعا الصلاه بالعينين
طبعا اتمنينا اقوللك انا واحد من الناس
تمنيت اموت من اول الحرب ولا اشوف كلها
اللي هناك